would you describe yourself
as a nerd when you were growing up
um I would happily put myself in that
category yeah I uh I I got glasses in
the second grade oh my God and
um and I went to the same school from
pre-first through
12th grade oh wow and so once you get
glasses in in that kind of situation
like you're you're locked in you're just
you're a nerd and you don't have a say
in the matter it doesn't it's not a
reflection of your behavior or anything
like I I was still very athletic or
whatever but I had glasses from second
grade on and and I never changed my peer
group you know I was always jealous of
the kids that would come in from other
schools because I would be like no one
knows your history you what if you were
a nerd at your school now everyone
thinks you're cool you're like a shiny
new object and I never never really got
that opportunity so yes I was a nerd the
chance to reinvent yourself which is
everyone's dream at that time period I
was lucky because I would switch every
couple of years
um uh my old man would have to move on
when the credit ran out and uh
just running from HBO Hotel
the occasional Showtime Hotel
get out of here we don't have HBO we got
showtime uh but anyway so I was able to
try and reinvent but never did yeah
always quickly reverted to form yeah so
um so you you had glasses and what were
your interests were you musical back
things you're you're you're quite an
accomplished musician were you musical
back then yeah I started doing
um
I started taking piano lessons when
I think I was probably eight or so and I
but I also and the funny thing is my
sister had taken piano lessons and so I
I and she's older than me
um and her so I I grew up with her
practicing piano and so that just was a
very normalized thing and I just and I
wound up begging my parents for piano
lessons and uh and so that's when I
started I got my first guitar
uh as a Christmas present I think I was
13. remember what guitar was yeah yeah
of course I still have it it was a um
it's an acoustic guitar it's a Gibson
Nouveau which is a it's a it was a it
was a little period of time in the 80s
where Gibson was having Gibson brand
guitars made in Japan yeah and uh and
this particular little pocket of guitars
the Nouveau models there there were also
12 string nouvos as well as Nouveau
mandolins and they they all have pretty
high marks from from Guitar nerds who
evaluate these things and it was like a
I think it was about a 400 guitar which
is which is like a a higher end
entry-level guitar at least for me at
that point and I just was blown away by
this thing it was so shiny and and it
just smelled good there's something
about I feel like real guitar nerds are
obsessed with how their guitars smell
yeah particularly acoustic guitars
because the inside like if you put your
nose up to that hole what
that sounds terrible No No One's Gonna
Fall No One's Gonna
one's gonna take that out of context so
you get your nose right up to the hole
right up in that hole oh my God there's
nothing lagging and there's a g string
there right oh God there's a g string
you got to push that out of the way
um I have both you disappointed me and I
have new respect for you both Matt right
now
I live most comfortably yeah in equal
measure yes
um but yeah that was my first guitar and
then
um and then and then my introduction to
the banjo was It was kind of interesting
I I loved bluegrass music already and I
was kind of a a big fan and I always
wanted to play a banjo but it was this
sort of exotic thing that I that I just
didn't have access to I didn't know
anyone who had a banjo right and then
all of a sudden my high school wanted to
do
a production of this uh kind of obscure
musical called The Cotton Patch gospel
which is a a it's it's the it's it's a
it's the gospel story but as a Bluegrass
Musical and it's a comedy it's really
pretty pretty brilliant and the songs
are all written by Harry Chapin yeah and
they're uh and and they're great it's
just they're great songs and they're
Bluegrass tunes and they were like wait
do we want to do it but nobody plays the
banjo and I was like give me two months
and I'll learn these songs I'm picturing
you too whipping your glasses off yeah
give me two months and you've got
another pair of glasses underneath yeah
and uh give me two months oh we're in
that banjo and my so yeah my my guitar
teacher at the time was also a banjo
teacher he one of his students was a
collector and and loaned me one and and
we just got to work you know started
wood shedding on these these tunes and I
didn't learn them well but I learned
them well enough and I it was like a a
drug I just loved playing that the banjo
it's interesting because my primary
interest was comedy just and and it was
foggy but I was very interested in
learning to play uh guitar
but comedy was first and I remembered
thinking ah the banjo looks cool maybe I
could learn the banjo and then thinking
no
Steve Martin did that so that door is
closed to me and I remember you look at
it now like wait I can't play the banjo
for my own fun and enjoy because
um Steve Martin already did that and I
remember thinking I know it'll me I'll
be so needy that I'll pull it into
whatever kind of way I'm trying to be
comic and so that's closed to me so the
banjo is closed to me completely so
I despise Steve Martin for that sure
sure he yeah that's such a that is
really such a comedy prism through which
to make to like evaluate something it's
how I looked uh at everything for a
period in my life yeah and and my first
guitar was uh
um because I started later I was a bad
drummer uh who morphed into a bad
guitarist but I I
uh decided no I need to know how to play
the guitar and I really want to know how
so uh a friend who knew something about
it went with me and I went to Freedom
guitar and bought it for ninety dollars
I bought a Yamaha acoustic
that I still have and it's fantastic
they're great they're so great
especially that time when was that what
was probably I think I bought it in 85
but it would have been a 1970s Yamaha
and it was great and what's interesting
and I promise I'll get us off nerdy
guitar talk but
since then I've had access to
um you know Martins and just these you
know sort of I mean now they make so
many so many different companies make
beautiful yes bespoke
uh uh guitars and I've had my chance to
have all of them but I still have this
fondness for yup the 90 Yamaha
it worked fine that was a great era for
the Yamaha guitars for real and they're
those are also
highly appreciated to this day can I ask
you something
added the whole smell oh
I'm glad how did that yamaha's hole
smell
from one guitar nerd to another well
I'll just tell you then uh I would
always sprinkle nutmeg into the hole and
you can take that any way you want okay
anyway it goes for all fraternity I'm
taking it in like the butthole way sorry
oh no no no no no no no no no no I put
vanilla up there
nutmeg is for the instrument
that feels like it would burn I don't
know it's a vanilla extract or like a
vanilla ice cream
I meant the extract yeah because that's
it that's yeah it's pure alcohol yeah
that's that's like it's sanitary okay
yeah well the hard part is finding
someone who will apply it that's the
tricky part I often will uh try and pay
a pastry chef to do it and they're like
I'm not into this well I pay them very
well why did we get on this I don't know
I but I do I could go down the nerdy
guitar stuff for days yeah I have like
my favorites I have to be careful there
have been several times uh on this
podcast where guitars come up and then
if it's between that and vanilla up your
butt let's go with guitars okay feel
free I like vanilla up the butt I'm
sorry I love guitars but are you talking
about what are you talking you want to
talk about that
you just said you just said I really
love vanilla you've got children you
have two babies at home oh my God this
is something your kids are gonna be
teased about in the schoolyard no come
on all right yeah
uh well this is all Ed helms's fault
yeah a dirty dirty comic yeah
I wanted to get the only the one and
only clean interview with Ed Helms and
already are I won't let you do it